Bronwen Horst kind enough to not reboot
his phone and call us up I assume it is
that on that actual phone
Brian Matt you're calling it to the show
right now yes it is and it's the most
updated shown in Los Angeles now did you
hit the button by accident
I mean Wes oh gosh you know if you have
an iPhone it pops up like out of nowhere
time to update right who says now or
later and I was working a laptop and the
phone I thought I hit later and I didn't
and you know if you want to buy
something from iTunes you had to say yes
seven times right put in a password and
agree to new terms and conditions you
hit update now that's it there's no
going back and unfortunately it was
after Jimmy Butler trades okay and I
contributed some reporting of aspects
that trade and nothing happened in that
window that was severe but I was you
know my I was annoyed amused but just
helpless home for about 15 minutes about
to say how long were you off the grid
run how long about 15 and then somebody
somebody suggested that I plug it into
the computer and that actually sped it
up so okay
that helped yeah I mean that's if you
don't mind me I'm not trying to rub salt
arrest that's kind of like a rookie
mistake Brian you're better than it's a
terrible mistake and and honestly it
happened during free agency you afraid
to see less over the course of days and
things change this is during the lottery
of the dividend was a second round it
wouldn't even be the big deal right just
was during the lottery of the draft Wow
Wow
okay well I'm glad what I should have
good karma now for at least six months
the most updated phone though in Los
Angeles Bronwyn Norris using it to call
us into the Rich Eisen show so we just
had Tom Thibodeau on our show and he
said that there was no there there with
Ricky Rubio essentially what do you say
I don't buy it
because they have to they have to
upgrade shooting on their roster Jimmy
Butler trade was a was a Grand Slam for
them for a number of different reasons
but they still don't have enough
shooting they still are going to
struggle a little bit where teams are
not going to guard that position so I
don't think they're going to give them
away for nothing but Ricky Rubio has
been available on the market for a while
and you know part
being the president of a basketball team
is you have to live the media so I'll
give tip the pass okay and now let's
turn to the Rockets
Chris Paul trade why make this trade if
you're the Rockets if you could get
Chris Paul via free agency within 24
hours what was the genesis of this and
the leverage for any of the sides behind
it Brian
yeah so I'm going to tell you I don't
know whether this is going to make them
competitive with the Warriors but from a
general managing standpoint this was as
good of a general managing maneuvers as
I've seen in my 15 years in the league
and here's why the the Rockets didn't
have enough salary cap space to sign
Chris Paul outright so they would have
had to trade away players to sign him
anyway maybe not they wouldn't have
traded away these players but they
didn't give away any like super core
stuff and they upgrade the best player
they trade it was Beverly who they have
now upgraded to Chris Paul secondly by
getting him to opt into his contract
he's going to make 11 million dollars
less than he would have made if they'd
signed him outright they got a discount
and they made six trade yesterday rich
sick they went out and got five
non-guaranteed players to make the deal
three of which they still have on their
roster they still have fodder to make
other trades and I'm not going to bore
you with the details but they did the
trade in such a way that still allows
them to have eight and a half million
dollars to spend on one free agent and
three million dollars to spend on
another they could see reddit betrayed
for guy like Paul George and still add
to legitimate players in free agency
again I'm not saying they're beating the
Warriors I'm just saying
terrific movement by Daryl Morey and
I'll say this when you talk about an
analytics or Moneyball approach it
doesn't mean just going by numbers a lot
of times what it means is going for what
other teams are undervaluing
and what's being undervalued in the NBA
right now is aggression everybody's
seeing the calves and the warrior even
going you know what I'm going to have a
three year plan and there
Sene you know what no one's being
aggressive so if everybody's planning
for down the road when these teams age
if I be aggressive now I can go against
the grain and so I think he hit all
those boxes yesterday it may not work
but I understand why he did it so what
is Paul's plan Chris Paul is you're just
going to see how it goes for a year and
if that's the case you don't need to be
a private detective to look around and
see who else is at the end of their
contract by the end of Chris Paul's and
check out LeBron Chris Paul tandem
shopping for a team a couple of years
from now
Brian next year next summer is eligible
if he wants to because he was traded the
Rockets retained his rights he is
eligible to sign a four-year extension
for 130 million should he want to but
the vibe is that he's not going to do
that he's going to see how it works for
a year which is again incredible for the
Rockets it wasn't like they traded the
number one overall pick for him if this
doesn't work in a year he leaves and
they saw the salary cap space I mean
like I said Grand Slam from from from a
general managing cat maneuvering asset
standpoint and going forward to next
year yeah LeBron will be a free agent
Dwayne will be a free agent Carmelo has
an opt-out I'm a little skeptical he's
going to leave 30 million on the table
or 28 or whatever it is but okay it
could happen and whether that team
actually is beating the Warriors the
different conversation but yes in theory
it leaves the door open for those guys
to play together so which team would be
able to raise their hands and say we'll
be the if you will conduit for the
banana boat gang what would a job for me
you want to be predict something in the
end I can't predict what's going to
happen on the NBA in 12 minutes you want
me to predict what's gonna happen twelve
yes I do Brian you've got the most
updated phone ever think think I owe
many updates between now and then mm-hmm
but I mean you could read the tea leaves
as to who would be creating a taffeta
you know I don't think it's going to be
the Charlotte Hornets you know I mean I
you know the the Lakers are going to be
in some position but for those guys to
play together it's going to first off
they're all up there and a
they're all little long in the tooth all
right and secondly it was going to
require massive amounts of leaving money
on the table for these guys yeah and I
realize they've all made a bunch of
money but it's going to be all their
last contracts so if you can convince me
that they're all willing to play for ten
million dollars next year you know then
we could talk about that it could happen
in LA but you know in until I until I
see that they're willing to do that it's
kind of hard to project that right now
but sure though both the Clippers and
Lakers could be in position to do it
hell the Rockets could potentially be in
position to do it depending on the way
they manage their caps going forward you
know there's you know to me I would
think that they would want to go join at
least a team that has another star
player that's younger that they can sit
around so we'll see maybe Lonzo ball
wins Rookie of the Year and that's the
guy they want maybe Brandon Ingram has a
breakout sophomore year wins Most
Improved Player and and that's the guy
they want to come to we'll have to see
there's no doubt in my mind Brian no
doubt in my mind that Los Angeles would
lose their minds if the Lakers were able
to do that for two three years like the
NBA's Traveling Wilburys or cocoon 3
however you want to call it at the end
of their careers there's no doubt in my
mind Staples would be sold out through
the roof and the Lakers would be into
something like that I think well as a
big Tom Petty and Roy Orbison Santis
Traveling Wilburys hits me where I live
ok I took I think would be amazing
I don't know if it's a championship team
and maybe those guys don't care maybe
you'd be like you know we just want to
have fun at the end and if the Lakers
want to facilitate that I will say this
the one thing about the Lakers have they
have young players on cheap on cheap
contracts so you know again if Lonzo
ball and Brandon Ingram have explosive
year and those guys could come in and
make the money while those guys are
still playing out their rookie contract
it could be something it could be it's
definitely something to watch for sure
and these guys have gone on the record
you know LeBron went on the record
saying you know this would be amazing if
we could pull this off so we'll see if
the cows wouldn't
championship I find it hard to believe a
bronze gonna walk away from that if the
Rockets get to the to the Western
Conference final and have a seven game
series and losing a barn burner to the
Warriors I find it hard to believe Chris
Paul is not going to want to strap it
back up and try to win but yes to get
where you're going and to get people
excited I could see it happening under
certain circumstances last one for you
Brian when Horst Paul George does he get
moved in the first week of free agency
what happened so I think he's got to get
trade there's no way he can because
Kevin Pritchard the the president kind
of indicated they leave all to bring in
a training camp there's no way that's
happening it's the situation is bad
there now basically sniping at each
other encodes through the media so I do
think he's getting traded probably in
the next seven to ten days what it looks
like is happening is the Pacers are
going to wait and see if free agency
changes the offers that they're getting
and the place to watch here is Boston if
Boston can land Gordon Hayward and then
you know they can be more of a long-term
option for Paul George that he maybe be
willing to consider an extension that
may change what they're willing to offer
if Paul if Gordon Hayward stays in Utah
goes to Miami I don't know if the
Celtics offer gets better but I think
the Pacers aren't thrilled with their
offers right now and they think the free
agency and stuff that happens in free
agency it will give them a chance to
have those offers improved Brian thanks
very much for calling and since your
will Barry fan now that you have updated
your phone and you're back on the grid
you're not alone anymore Brian how about
that one there you got it all right
Bronwen worst of ESPN the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to